hey guys I'm Brent rose tech writer and
Georgia's coolest grandma so as you know
California is in the middle of an
unprecedented drought in fact just back
in April Governor Jerry Brown issued the
state's first mandatory water
restrictions in its history which is
good but those restrictions were only
for municipal water usage and while we
should be drought shaming wasteful
celebrities for their gigantic emerald
green lawns those guys are dicks
municipal water usage is just a small
slice of the watery pizza-pie a whopping
80 percent of California's water usage
goes toward agriculture 80 and there's a
reason behind that California is the
country's most productive agricultural
state by a huge margin between livestock
fruit nuts vegetables and eggs it's a 50
billion dollar a year industry
so obviously growing food is important
but some foods guzzle a lot more water
than others so how do you know which is
which if you have vegetarian friends on
Facebook you've probably heard something
to the effect of if you really want to
save water don't eat meat and sorry meat
eaters they're kind of right it takes
638 gallons of water to give you just a
6 ounce piece of beef that's a ton of
water for just a little steak actually
it's two point six six tons of water
this isn't just because cows are thirsty
little buggers it's because of how much
water goes into growing their feet we'll
come back to that in a minute but for
now just know that yes beef is the worst
offender as far as water usage even if
you break it down as gallons per calorie
or gallons per gram of protein beef is
the worst but don't get too smug yet
vegetarians while beef is the worst and
lamb is close behind two of your
favorite proteins are almost as bad
lentils use 570 gallons and garbanzo
beans use a crazy 609 gallons of water
to produce 8 ounces of food in contrast
8 ounces of chicken requires just 133
gallons in other words chickpeas consume
4 and a half times more water than
chickens
so if beef is the worst protein which is
the best well by most metrics it's the
incredible edible quibble if you look at
how many gallons of water per gram of
protein you get eggs win handily at 3.6
7 gallons per gram chicken comes in
second at 4.76 gallons per gram sheep
meat is the worst at 20 2.13 followed
closely by beef at 20 point to 6 the
humble egg wins in water to calorie
ratio to
just a quarter gallon per calorie beef
handily loses this one coming in at 2.5
gallons per calorie in other words the
egg uses just over 1/10 the amount of
water per calorie that beef does help
you visualize all of this imagine each
one of these plastic cups is a full
gallon of water so you know how okra is
kind of slimy and you're always looking
for an excuse not to eat it well here
you go
it takes 62 gallons to make eight ounces
of Oprah asparagus is even worse coming
in at 163 gallons compare that to real
water sippers like carrots which use 7.4
gallons and that's a huge contrast how's
about fruit in the middle we have
raspberries coming in at 34 gallons and
nectarines coming in at 38 gallons per 8
ounces at nearly double that we have
avocados at 72 gallons but here's the
thing try and take away a Californians
avocado and he will hunt you down and
murder your children besides there are
way worse fruit out there cherries come
in at a whopping ninety eight gallons
per eight ounces which is a shame
because I love those things if there's
any ray of sunlight and all of this its
strawberries those little growers come
in at just ten gallons per eight ounces
I was about a tasty beverage to wash
that down milk is pretty bad coming in
at forty four gallons orange juice is a
bit better coming in thirty three
gallons and wine is better still coming
in at twenty two but you know it's
better than all of that beer beer is
only sixteen gallons per eight ounces
although nobody drinks beer in eight
ounce
increments so if we're looking at a
sixteen ounce pint and we're talking
about 32 gallons of water compare that
with a more realistic 6 ounce pour of
wine which is only about 20 so okay wine
is the better one but it you drink
beer
here's how some other foods stack up
Brussels sprouts
nineteen point five gallons daters
twenty three point eight gallons huevos
ninety three point eight gallons is
baguette the one hundred thirty two
point eight gallons cheek angled one
hundred thirty two point nine gallons
toad foo 151 gallons shed at one hundred
eighty point two gallons almonds one
hundred eighty four gallons 330 gallons
Lennon tolls five hundred seventy
gallons gonna bundle beans 609 gallons
both eight hundred and fifty point two
gallons so how does this look in the
context of meals what we invited
registered dietitian nutritionist
Jessica Gutterman to come in here and
put together a few meals for us they're
high in protein solid on calories and
fiber and are rich in vitamins and
minerals the difference Oh only six
hundred and fifty gallons of water plate
a uses a whopping eight hundred and
thirteen gallons of water plate B is at
least as good nutritionally speaking but
it only requires a hundred sixty three
gallons to make in other words you could
make plate B for five different people
before you equal the water consumption
of just one plate a we did this to show
you how much of an impact the choices
you make can have it every single meal
multiply that by three meals a day seven
days a week and that's a massive amount
of water okay so you've got all this
information what do you do with it well
for starters you should check out
Wired's guide to produce that won't make
the drought worse our own joanna
Pearlstein crunches an exhaustive amount
of data and used it to rank various
crops by water usage and organize them
by season the result is a very handy
chart you can print out and stick on
your fridge or just download to your
phone but lastly what about almonds
major news outlets have been slandering
them and they become a very public
villain but as gizmo toes elisa walker
points out it's really not so much we're
talking about a hundred eighty four
gallons per eight ounces which is just
above asparagus but it's still a
fraction of what beef pork and chicken
peas use you have to look at what you
get for that water expenditure for
starters you get a high protein high
calorie food so nutritionally you're
getting a lot of bang for your buck but
you're getting a lot of buck for your
buck too last year alone almonds brought
in eleven billion dollars of revenue to
the state of california so if you want a
villain to blame who's a better target
surprise a Keyser söze of California
agriculture
is alfalfa but it's not because the
sprouts on your salad we use more water
growing alfalfa than we do any other
single agricultural product we're
talking 15% or more compared that to 10%
for almonds but unlike our little nut
buddies alfalfa isn't used to feed
humans it's used to feed cows and not
even American cows what the hell is
going on here California uses over a
million acres to grow alfalfa yet only a
small fraction of that goes to feeding
california's cows the vast majority of
it is shipped overseas largely used to
pay down our national trade debt to
China in 2011 the Port of Los Angeles
alone shipped 2.4 million metric tons of
animal feed the majority of which was
alfalfa grown in California this is the
equivalent of shipping off 2.4 billion
gallons of water in the middle of an
incredibly severe drought that's
completely insane so what did we learn
here today obviously we're all hoping
that the drought will end very soon in
the meantime you've got some more
information to make some better choices
and maybe there's a representative you
want to call about certain policies I
don't know let us know in the comments
below what food surprised you the most
subscribe to Wired if you haven't
already and with that being said there's
only one thing left to do
[Music]